I also want to congratulate you on the
movie Eurovision Song Contest the story
of fire saga I watched this last night
another enjoyable romp I have to tell
you I really enjoyed it but I didn't
know anything about Eurovision Song
Contest is a real thing that you've been
obsessed with for a while is that right
yes it is a it's been going on for 60
plus years and every year it's watched
from anywhere to a hundred and eighty to
two hundred million people it is one of
the craziest things you'll ever see I
discovered it literally 20 years ago
with my wife we were visiting her family
in Sweden and we had had dinner and all
of a sudden her cousin was like so shall
we watch and I was like okay yeah what's
that
and and sat there for three hours
mesmerised by I had no idea what was
going on it is it is like Cirque du
Soleil me American Idol meets I don't
know a residency show in Vegas it's it's
it's the craziest thing you've ever seen
also meets the Olympics because it's
different countries going up against
each other and one of the things you
capture in this movie is there is
something about European entertainment
and that is very specific and so you in
the movie you portray people singing
like rock power ballads dressed as
Vikings that's something that really
could happen on Eurovision a hundred
percent and it's it's so foreign to us
as Americans you know we any sort of our
competitive music shows we're we're
pretty much into looking as cool as we
can in your vision it's quite the
opposite even though they fully believe
they're looking as cool as possible but
yeah you'll
you'll see everything from costumes a
lot of pyrotechnics a lot of people just
onstage doing nothing that has anything
to do with the song including one of the
actually will been to three of them in
person and one of the bits that we
actually lifted and put in the movie was
I think I believe it was the Ukraine and
this this singer was was singing but
behind them on the stage was a man just
running in a life human-sized hamster
wheel for three minutes and was never
referenced in any way
and I don't think with the song nothing
to do the song the singer didn't look
back be the the they even got a tight
shot of the guy running in the hamster
wheel and he just kept running he
wouldn't even look at the camera
[Music]
and we were obsessed with that image
that we we ended up putting it in the
movie you know what I loved is that
you're in the hamster wheel yeah pull
out but unlike the example you just gave
you also have to sing while you're
running full out in the hamster wheel
wait looks hilarious and I imagine was
next to impossible well it is one of
those moments where and I found myself
on numerous occasions over my career
when I read something on the page I
forget that I'm actually gonna have to
do it and there I was on that day being
hoisted about fifty feet above the
ground
you know hamster wheel that I kind of
had to control with my own gate and then
singing the lyrics but you know we got
it done you got it done yeah got it done
in style I uh but but the the prop
master did remind me on several
occasions how difficult it was to build
that hamster wheel that's like okay but
isn't that your job
yeah but I'm just telling you there's 97
there's 96 weld joints alone on that
piece of steel huh all right okay thank
you yeah thank you
I think he was looking for a big thank
you thank you thank you
yeah said thank you more I should have
sent him Omaha Steaks you uh you reveal
that you have quite a nice singing voice
will and I it leads me to wonder what
about you putting out an album
Will Ferrell sings is that something the
good happen you know it could you never
know but I would probably be drawn to
more of a spoken word album I'd love to
bring back spoken word I mean just
saying lyrics bang the lyrics not
actually singing the song and not like
eight or ten songs thirty to fifty song
spoken word
that's gonna be a very very long album
you're gonna you're gonna want to sit
back and really really be able to
dedicate a nice chunk of time to it yeah
I think you're gonna want to listen to
it as you drive from LA to bother then
and you're gonna maybe just get through
all the songs maybe as you get to
Framingham mass exactly in fact I'm
gonna that's how I'm gonna do a dry run
where I time it so that when you pull
into Framingham you finish the album
okay this sounds like a awful idea thank
you you've given me a great idea
now don't don't do it
it's a bad no God no your there's a
scene in the movie you know I know no
don't don't make your spoken word out no
no salute no no one has ever saluted
Thank You Conan such a bad idea